Ron let's start with this we've been
talking about Greg Holland the closer
for the Rockies getting hurt cutting
himself with a knife in a kitchen the
oddest baseball injury anyone on your
team ever experienced was what Oh
my team geez I mean I've heard all the
stories you probably heard all the
stories too from John Smoltz which is
not true he told me ironing his shirt on
while he was wearing it to weigh about
lannister like that putting his cowboy
boots on right so I've heard all the
footage I don't think I've ever played
with a player who who had you know
missed a couple of games I've had
players that have overdone it the night
before and didn't like show up for a day
but I didn't I never had like a bow of
course I remember that Bobby Ojeda
missed the playoffs in 1988 I believe
because of a gardening accident
apparently he was trimming his hedges
and and had a gardening accident and
missed the postseason so that's a lot as
bad as it gets as a lifelong Mets fan
when Ron darling joined Junie 2 that had
guys overdo it that's the most obvious
statement ever right when you come in
consider with your day that's I mean is
there a such thing as overdoing it with
your 86 Mets
isn't that just doing it listen I'm a
dark person so I was even blushy as I
was saying no this is your first on such
thing as overdoing it with that Club but
the one thing that separated that Club
from any other team that ever played on
is that once you know the bell rang at
7:00 7:30 whatever time the game started
they not only wanted to beat you two
wanted to rip your heart out and I never
ever played on a team like that I played
on so unbelievable competitive teams but
that team was was angry or and and
different another teams that played on
you know one of my favorite teams about
things about that team that probably a
lot of the younger fans don't know about
and it would be like a whole
controversial social media thing if it
happened today the 86 Mets used to do
this thing the hotfoot right like that
where you would like guys feet on fire
during games right explains it to people
what that was
well it was Roger McDowell who who
really perfected it he was in our
bullpen in 86 he won 14 games since 822
it's pretty good right so in between the
14 wins and 22 saves what he used to do
is take a matches and gum and all kind
of other stuff roll it all up together
stick it to the back of someone so and
then light it on fire and literally you
know the thing about it was the reaction
because everyone thinks what's the heart
foot why would it matter but people who
have had one says it really feels like
your foots burning up and you know
luckily it's not really hurting you but
he was a master of it and did it all the
time and for whatever reason you know
certain things happen over and over and
you just can't stop laughing that was
one of them and the players we never
know because he was I climb underneath
the dugout leader could be underneath
the dugout Bank or underneath the
benches and they would literally light
it on fire it was amazing watching this
is a great video that I have watched
about a thousand times 1986 a year to
remember which is the greatest light
year in review show for the Mets and
they literally focus on that because it
was so funny alright let's get into a
couple of modern-day baseball things
here what is this what is this week like
for players trade deadline what what
goes on in that Clubhouse in that locker
room as you lead up to July 31st how
nervous are guys in that locker room
well I don't know I don't know if
nervous is the word because you know
they're professional so I don't say
nervous third but I think that everyone
around them is on a tender hooks because
you know your family is going to be
uprooted everyone that you know so
everyone else around you is kind of very
nervous as far as you're concerned I
think what you have to do is what are
you going to be traded or not is that
you've got to see value and how well you
do so you can't let you know the
circumstance of maybe being traded to
overwhelm how you play every single day
because if you're still going to remain
with the same team you're with you want
to perform at a high level and if a team
wants to acquire you you want to perform
at a high level so it's not that hard I
think the difference is in the
clubhouses
is when management goes and acquires
some real key players like
clubhouse for a week at least are so
excited and pumped up like boy you know
they believe in us who can go out get
this thing and and the same thing
applies for the pessimism on a team that
thinks they're close and the front
office does nothing I think that's the
Teva you know also for a week go boy
nice the front office job couldn't even
go get us a relief pitcher or whatever
we needed so you know that's that's
really where it lies Dallas Keuchel
Astro starter calls out his team would
you feel worse if you were Geoff Luna
the general manager not making the moose
or Francisco Liriano who was actually
acquired by the extras and actually
brought in there yeah I was still
warmest if I was Dallas Keuchel haven't
been able to make all this starts
calling the [ __ ] office out interest you
know that's hard to do when you're not
out there he said they are doing it
because of your own own injury I always
felt this way about fun office and maybe
it was different in my day because you
know you really let's say respected
because these guys respected for an
office they do but I think they feel
because of the money made they feel a
little more worthy that their you know
opinion means or as opposed to I played
you really felt like the front office
considered you part of like a widget you
know part of the bit was a big plan so
you never really voiced your opinion
about those kind of things
I applaud players that do it I'm just I
think that this is so hard to just play
baseball that that dealing with being a
GM to is above and beyond and in my
estimation I think anyone should have
their own opinion I think that's great I
would hold line side with Ron darling
TBS SNY they have on TBS the matchup on
Sunday Nats and Cubs 2 p.m. Eastern Time
fill in the blank for me blank is the
most impressive part of the LA Dodgers
boy um
impressive partly because there are many
so many impressive part I think I think
the the freedom with which they play the
game is the most underrated part they've
got talent and I know we all know
and we know that Cody Bellinger's having
an unbelievable first 90 games in the
big leagues but Dave Roberts you know as
a second-year manager and it was great
in his first year has been perfect with
today's athlete allowing them the
freedom to just play their game in the
style that they play it you know a lot
of old-school guys that are my age are
not into the do kind of school or not
you know I'm not one of those I think
that the only way to get the best out of
your athlete is to really let them be
themselves and I think Dave Roberts does
that better not better but he does it as
well as any other manager in baseball
and I think that's why the talent is
flowing in Los Angeles because
everyone's freed up Ron better edition
centigrade for the Yankees or Yu Darvish
for the Dodgers well it's a real tough
question because the Yu Darvish of being
traded to the Dodgers not pitching that
well going in I'm going to say though
you ask me the question I go you Darvish
the only reason I'm saying this is that
I think you Darvish was a really great
ballclub is going to find his pace I
also think you know there's a large a
large community there and Los Angeles
that's going to make him feel at home
and I think Sonny gray the only thing
that always I'm afraid of with Sonny
gray is nervous performance because he's
one of the gutsiest pitchers in baseball
it's his health and that's the thing
that always scares me now listen czar
which has been hurt too but I thought
you asked me the question I think
Darvish will do better because I think
the Dodgers are better team if I told
you right now one of these two teams
would be in the World Series which one
would you say is more likely the Yankee
to the Red Sox oh I'm going to say the
Red Sox and the reason I say that is I
think that you know the the pitching of
the bullpen now the addition of read2go
with timbrel and others I think that
they're best young players have not even
played to their best even though Mookie
Betts has been amazing and then
attendees having a real good year but
knows Bogaerts is not having as good a
years he did last year and I think
they're going to eject a Bradley jr. to
me is not having a good year so I think
those guys are going to find it because
they're too good not to find it and and
I think what's going to happen to the
Yankees and even though they've added
some really solid pitching is that
they've got a lot of young players that
are going to be playing six months of
baseball as opposed to five months and
that September is going to feel like the
Bataan Death March to them and and and
that's why I think the Red Sox have a
better chance interesting hadn't thought
about it that way we think about that a
lot with other sports but that's such a
good point because I mean so many these
guys are the Yankees we're in the minors
the last however many years and this is
their first full big-league season and
then not only first Wrigley season but
under this extreme spotlight every
single day that that's something that
you can't teach it's something that you
can't even have a veteran player tell
you that you have to go look up for
yourself promise finish with this so
much buzz this week and I I don't see a
comp maybe you do I saw a lot of
baseball writers talking about the
Warriors of the NBA you know Dave them
under the other baseball dave dombrowski
joking with Cashman cashman's joked with
Dombrowski is there a team that you
would say is the Golden State Warriors
of Major League Baseball well I mean if
you pick Lee during the regular season
you have the daughters you know they're
42 or 43 games over 500 that's an
amazing record at this conjunction you
know I played on the team that won 108
games so I kind of know what it's like
to be on a team like that but yeah I
guess I mean yeah I have to go to the
Dodgers right now there's a team that's
really the Golden State Warriors even
though it's the regular season but do
you know anything can happen in the
postseason of baseball since the second
wild-card it is an extreme grind for
these players so anyone who's hot and we
saw this with the Mets a couple of
seasons ago when they went through not
only the Dodgers Oh people could argue
was a better team but they also went
through the Cubs in four games and a lot
of people picked the 2015 Cubs to go all
the way so that's the thing about
baseball whoever's playing hottest has
the best chance
Ron great job thank you so much for
watching Sunday 2:00 p.m. Eastern on TBS
for the Nationals and the Cubs I
appreciate it thank you guys appreciate
it the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
audience